[Musica]
oggi voglia di mostrarvi come le
difficoltà sono delle cose importanti
le difficoltà sono importanti per
diverse ragioni le difficoltà ci
definiscono ci identificano senza il
nostro vissuto senza le difficoltà che
abbiamo vissuto difficilmente possiamo
capire chi siamo le difficoltà ci
aiutano a far capire quanta forza c'è
dentro di noi se noi non viviamo una
determinata difficoltà nella nostra vita
difficilmente usciamo dalla nostra zona
di confort e difficilmente impariamo a
capire come siamo fatti come possiamo
risolvere dei problemi
oggi voglio raccontarvi la storia di
come l'arte di raccontare storie in
qualche modo mi abbia aiutato a salvare
la vita mia e ad inventarmi un lavoro
online infatti il mio lavoro oggi è
proprio quello di documentare la mia
vita sui social media facciano youtuber
oltre a tutte le altre cose che hanno
detto all'inizio quindi vivo raccontando
storie la mia storia
adesso immaginatevi nel vostro mondo
ordinario siete nel vostro letto è una
martedì mattina del 17 ottobre del 2017
fuori fa freddo e il sole non vuole
sapere di sorgere voi siete rintanati
nei vostri sogni e non volete cambiare
nulla della vostra vita sta andando
tutto a gonfie vele andate
all'università
fate la magistrale avete da poco finito
un master in marketing e avete fatto uno
stage quindi va tutto perfettamente fin
quando quella mattina del 17 ottobre
un grido gelido
una voce femminile di sveglia dai vostri
sogni e vi catapulta in un momento
inaspettato in qualcosa di nuovo quelle
grida erano le grida di mia madre le
sento subito e in un momento esatto mi
sveglio lancio fuori le coperte da letto
e lancia dall'altra parte quasi colpendo
mio fratello e mi sveglio già piangendo
come se sapessi quello che stavo per
scoprire mi fiondo nella camera dei miei
genitori e riesco per l'ultima volta ad
abbracciare il corpo di mio padre quel
giorno oltre alla perdita di mio padre
perdo una parte di me perdo la mia
fanciullezza perdo la forza bruta dei
miei 25 anni
in realtà insieme a quella perdita perdo
tanto altro perdo la possibilità di
poter sognare era uno studente
squattrinato non avevo soldi non avevo
la forza di affrontare determinate
difficoltà
in quel periodo il mio sogno oltre a
scrivere libri oltre a studiare era
quello di scrivere libri volevo
raccontare storie volevo fare il
romanziere studiavo economia ma volevo
scrivere libri e mio padre mi aveva
detto se vuoi realizzare questo sogno
devi laurearti quindi avevo portato
avanti entrambe le passioni
in realtà la mia vera passione non era
tanto quella di scrivere libri volevo
raccontarli volevo dire alle persone
ehilà sono qui esisto e avevo scoperto
che avevano inventato il self publishing
l'auto pubblicazione e quindi io potevo
portare avanti due passioni quella dei
social media è quella del self
publishing infatti auto pubblicando i
miei libri avevo inventato diversi
format su instagram ed ero riuscita
addirittura ad arrivare a 10 mila
followers
grazie alle strategie sui social riesco
ad attirare tante persone che si
incuriosiscono alle mie storie comprano
i miei libri e capisco il potenziale dei
social dico cavoli
documentando online questa passione
posso vendere libri posso guadagnare
soldi e possono vivere della mia
passione
infatti il mio libro auto pubblicato tra
l'altro nella copertina ho fatto mille
errori era tra i più venduti
grazie a questa vendita che aveva
riscosso online attirò l'attenzione di
una casa editrice quindi in quegli anni
pubblico il mio primo romanzo con una
casa editrice e sono nelle librerie ho
realizzato il mio sogno e sto facendo un
tour in tutta italia per promuovere il
libro infatti quella mattina del 17
ottobre
mi trovavo a napoli per puro caso perché
volevo mostrare a mio padre che ce
l'avevo fatta che il mio sogno si era
realizzato il lunedì prima che lui
morisse vi avevo mostrato proprio queste
foto mi avevano intervistato
le versioni erano venuti a vedermi e
qualcuno si commuoveva mentre gli
autografato il libro è un partito dei
social dalla mia cameretta fighissimo
però la realtà è diversa non posso più
sognare non ci sono più soldi non c'è la
mano sicura di mio padre non ci sono
tante sicurezze che fino a quel momento
avevo quindi devo affrontare la realtà
dal mondo ordinario che conoscevo
arrivo nel mio mondo straordinario un
mondo sconosciuto fatto di sacrifici
fatto di dolore e depressione vedevo che
il mondo era grigio le persone erano
tristi e dovevo iniziare a lavorare
quasi abbandono l'università mi
mancavano due esami per la specialistica
iniziò a lavorare come praticante
commercialista in realtà sbobinato parte
davanti al computer per 12 ore e non mi
piaceva per niente era noiosissimo ed
ero triste ero proprio giù di morale non
potevo più realizzare il mio sogno e
nello storytelling nell'arte di
raccontare storie avviene un qualcosa ad
un certo punto la cosiddetta chiamata
all'avventura qualcosa che ti fa capire
che devi affrontare le difficoltà per
realizzare i tuoi sogni così incontro
per puro caso una figura mistica nel suo
paesello un personaggio atipico un folle
fa il fotografo non se ne frega
minimamente degli altri 0 cammino a
barba lunghissima capelli non se ne
frega niente mi fa un'unica e sola
domanda in questo discorso che io
ricordo e questa la vita che sognavo di
fare
lo guardo lo osservo io volevo fare
tutt'altro ma non posso scegliere perché
la vita mi ha messo di fronte a queste
difficoltà e lui mi dice tu puoi sempre
scegliere se tu a decidere cosa vuoi
fare nella tua vita e come lo vuoi fare
quindi guarda in che direzione vuoi
andare togli tutte le altre strade e
insegue quella strada quindi torno a
casa euforico pieno di voglia di vivere
e deciso di affrontare tutte le
difficoltà di quel momento la prima
prova era non lasciare nulla incompiuto
quindi finire l'università e laurearmi
faccio gli ultimi due esami
prendendo 18 me la sono cavata proprio
alla grande e mi laureo
seconda prova inizio comunque ad aver
bisogno di soldi mi hanno licenziato da
cui lavoro che non mi piacevano
noiosissimo e iniziò a mandare
curriculum a tutte le aziende di
marketing tutte perché comunque era
l'altra mia passione che avevo coltivato
indovinata e quante aziende mi hanno
risposto
ecco le
00 e nessuno del mio percorso
universitario
mi aveva preparato a tutti quei no mi
aveva preparato alle porte in faccia
quindi ero ancora più depresso
faccia una cosa che secondo me hanno
fatto tutti in questa stanza cerca su
google come fare soldi
mi compaiono mille esempi gente che fa
video e guadagna soldi gente che fa
social media e guadagna sordi gente che
ha competenza e le rivende online e
guadagna soldi cavoli devo fare questo
devo guadagnare soldi online
quindi trovo un po di persone che mi
ispirano la prima tra tutte è derivi che
arrivi a un personal brand fortissimo
tra l'altro avevo scoperto queste due
parole personal brand mi sono subito
innamorato e gari vi è nato in america
il padre era un immigrato
il padre aveva questione consiglio di
vini e la sua passione erano i vini
quindi partendo da una sua passione ha
iniziato a raccontare vini dei vini
tutti i vini che vendeva il padre tra
l'altro a facendo aumentare il fatturato
del negozietto del padre fino a 40
milioni di euro
oggi fa l'imprenditore nel mondo del
digital quindi è passato da una passione
a fare l'imprenditore
fighissimo
abbiamo la nostrana chiara ferragni
partendo dalla passione per la moda è
diventata imprenditrice che i sì nè
istat
partendo dalla sua passione per il video
making fallo youtuber ispira milioni di
youtuber collabora con grandi aziende e
fa l'imprenditore infine rupi kaur chi è
ruby karroubi kaur è una scrittrice fa
parte del movimento degli east ha poi
gli sta poi chi simone sono quegli
scrittori che grazie al potere dei
social media riescono a promuovere i
loro libri
a venderli fino a superare i migliori
autori del mondo nelle classifiche
mondiali quando scopro questo mi si
illuminano gli occhi devo portare questo
movimento in italia quindi
iniziò a fare due ricerche non c'era
nessuno che aveva parlato di questo
argomento in italia decido di farlo io
per chi era la mia passione l'obiettivo
era quello di documentare questa
passione documentare il mio percorso di
crescita come imprenditori in questa
nicchia e compro una vecchia videocamera
usata su internet insieme ad un vecchio
computer usato per editare video un po
di amici mi regalano il microfono chi dà
luce il cavalletto e iniziò a
documentare il tutto su youtube il
documento tutte le mie passioni tutto il
mio percorso di crescita personale e
finanziaria e oggi ho realizzato i miei
sogni tutto questo raccontando la mia
storia ogni giorno ogni settimana io
documento la mia storia e faccio lo
youtube air grazie al fatto che faccio
video su youtube un editore mi guarda su
youtube avevo fatto questo format sul
minimalismo lui era appassionato del
minimalismo e mi scrive vuoi scrivere un
libro io gli dico aspetta invece di
scrivere il libro io questa idea di
questo movimento in italia perchè non lo
fai con me decide di investire nella mia
idea io non avevo soldi lui investe
nella mia idea e oggi questo movimento
esiste e pubblica libri porta i ragazzi
a realizzare i loro sogni quindi il mio
sogno non è più quello di scrivere libri
ma aiutare gli altri a pubblicare il
loro libro e questa cosa mi riempie di
orgoglio sono partito dalla cameretta
adesso questi ragazzi pubblicano libri
perché ho realizzato tutto questo
partendo da un'idea semplicemente usando
i social media
oggi faccio la vita dei miei sogni se
incontrassi adesso quel fotografo e vi
ponesse la stessissima domanda è questa
la vita che sognavo di fare
risponderei di sì faccio la vita dei
miei sogni mi racconta online viaggio
nel mondo aiutando altri venditori a
fare quello che faccio io conosco
persone squisite speciali che allarga
nel mio network mi migliorano come
persona e migliorano anche come
imprenditore perché in qualche modo io
riesco ad assorbire la loro cultura in
realtà non ho fatto nulla di speciale
ho semplicemente preso una fotocamera e
documentato il mio percorso e così ho
costruito il mio personal brand siamo
partito dalla mia passione adesso faccio
tutt'altro anche ma ho semplicemente
raccontato la storia un po come ho fatto
oggi ho usato il viaggio dell'eroe che è
una tecnica di narrazione nello
storytelling c'è un partito dal mio
mondo ordinario fino ad arrivare al
mondo straordinario e poi affrontando
delle prove raggiunge il famoso premio a
cui ambiva
adesso non so chi di voi conosce questo
discorso di steve jobs a tutti
alla fine di questo discorso lì dice
guardandoci indietro possiamo unire i
puntini
io posso unire tutti i capitoli che ho
vissuto
ho imparato l'arte dello storytelling
non perché dovevo scrivere libri ma per
chi dovevo raccontarmi su youtube
ho imparato a vendere i miei libri non
perché dovessi vendere libri sui social
media ma perché dovevo aiutare le
aziende in un secondo momento a crescere
sui social e infine dovevo imparare
l'arte del videomaking per fare video
ogni tanto mi piace guardarmi alle
spalle vedere le difficoltà che ho
affrontato
non per piangermi addosso per fare la
vittima ma perché capisco da dove sono
venuto non
non mi piace volare di stare con i piedi
per terra sono partito da una cameretta
e oggi giro il mondo grazie ad una
passione e guardandomi indietro
la prima frase che mi ha reso virale sui
social è stata questa e mi andava di
lasciarvi con questa frase un po per
chiudere il cerchio di questa storia la
cito a memoria non ti annullare mai per
nessuna ragione
in seguito i sogni e si il meglio di ciò
che sei
[Applauso]